hallo verlag ist ja klaus hat kuchen
mitgebracht besonders schwägerin sonst
weggeworfen genau nehmen wir doch platz
es ist ein bekannter von mir das ist der
klaus halt 50 jahren spd-mitglied 50
jahre spd was ist aufstehen und warum
sollte da der klaus mitmachen
ja ich gehe mal davon aus wenn man in
die spd eingetreten ist dann doch weil
man irgendwie ein sozialeres land will
und ich glaube wenn ich aufstehen wenn
ich jetzt wirklich etwas neues versuchen
dann geht alles so weiter und dann geht
alles den bach runter am ende und
irgendwann sitzen eben typen wie holland
& co auch mal in der regierung die cdu
hat ja auch andere optionen was die spd
sie nicht dass schon der begriff
aufstehen auf jemanden wie klaus
abschreckend wirken könnte gut also
jeden morgen steht man auf als ich
manche leute finde es viel schöner war
eigentlich ist es ja doch so man wacht
auf wenn man aufgewacht ist steht man
auf ich habe in meinem leben oft genug
bestanden es gibt ja schon eine partei
die heißt die linke die sind im
wesentlichen für linke politik wie man
da schon so ein bisschen am namen
erkennt warum braucht klaus jetzt noch
eine linke bewegung
naja wenn die linke so stark wäre das
wer den bundeskanzler stellen könnten
oder wenn die spd so stark und vor allem
will ich wäre das zu machen wofür sie
mal ihren namen nach stand nämlich
soziale politik dann bräuchte man die
bewegung wahrscheinlich nicht fragt doch
mal was klaus kann ich noch kuchen noch
ein st
der mann hat ja schon mit großem erfolg
die spd kaputt gekriegt warum muss jetzt
auch noch die läden sich also er war
nicht der kanzler ist die spd den bach
runterging hat immerhin gar nichts mehr
zu tun als minister da nicht mehr drin
kann er nicht wie andere rentner einfach
mit dem e bike gefahren
also ich finde wir haben ganz viele
tolle leute und ich freue mich dass mein
mann natürlich auch mitmacht ist ja auch
für den ehrlichen frieden gut ist ja
auch ein harter schlag für die linke
dass ein star der partei einen eigenen
laden aufmacht
aber andererseits haben sie ja noch so
stars wie kipping und riexinger also ich
mach deinen laden auf sondern der laden
soll das was da ist ein linker politik
unterstützen und das bin ich dringend
notwendig und ich glaube jeder der in
der linken ist und ernsthaft mehr
soziale gerechtigkeit werde freut sich
darüber so klaus ist geht um dich auf
die basis und du kriegst jetzt die
abschlussfrage an die frau war okay sind
sie vielleicht noch singen mein gott
klaus ist total peinlich ich möchte mich
in aller form bei ihnen entschuldigen
und nicht verabschieden und herzlich
nicht bedacht zum thema ist erledigt